then all I'm with my good friend Chris
known as chess explained so today we had
game 7 I believe was it Chris game seven
today and right there just past the
halfway mark of the match now there's
only five games left after this sub game
seven it was ok so girlfriend with his
second white in a row plays d4 and we
get the familiar sloth defense um after
Knight c3 Knight f6 be free again so so
far we've had this in many games before
yeah we had this an all three em um girl
phone so white games are russia-led
games whatever you're going to just wish
it um yeah I'm a bit surprised that they
actually played this all the time so but
it shows that um einen obviously
believes this preparation is fine enough
to withstand all the constant tries to
ya to find something so we got exactly
the same opening as we had in Game one
three and five so long or three sorry
two four and six it's the other way
around so again this a 6-line here right
and now you know I six does seem to
intuitively we can be six and maybe you
know a lot of club players would think a
six is a bad move because you know maybe
this move which is played next seems
quite attractive in principle you know
the weakness of the last move here is
its kind of pounced on with this next
mode which varies from previous games
just to place c5 yay when c5 here it's
um of course I'm an interesting trifle
white and I'm also maybe the move which
young use the most turn lay in the
position compared to to the other lines
we've seen before where we had this mess
liquidation
and this boat happened here yeah but you
also need to see that white has his
bishop on c1 which is also not such a
great piece so if it was kind of
position with c-45 White's mission would
be on let's say a form then why would
certainly have some advantage yeah and
it's pretty obvious also the space
advantage enter this would would look
pretty nice it's not not losing or
anything for black but what should
should have something but am I mean he
tries to fix the b6 weakness but I see
what seemed hmm black dates night BTW
sandwich um so strategically also black
is often looking for a five if it
becomes possible yeah to get in maybeee
for that would liberate blacks position
because sometimes it's more difficult to
take eggs of c-5 but um the other
breakers is of course b6 as well as he
five that's the way to attack these two
parts of the chain let me let go
basically has to Plan C and B 635 he
could what you could try a white girls
night queen to see to now and well the
alternative I could think of them I
didn't look at the current state of
theory here the only alternative to be
six I could think of here is g6 yes yes
that that that looks as though that
Bishop might actually be really good
later for an e5 pawn sack it's built by
Knight g4 for example may be right Paul
Bishop would be good on that diagonal
I'm compact should be seven losses just
a better but you could play this so you
should do seven castles but this also
means that the bishop won't help them in
any way on the queenside you your Benden
any v6 plans then you really think
everything on this t5 break enter one
thing which which might be possible I'm
not sure if it's possible at the moment
but
a good at the moment and it's white
playing you for here let's say g6 and
I'm not sure maybe not immediately but
this would be one concern to open up now
the c1 bishop yeah and then something
which might be it might be an issue yeah
i'm not sure but v6s i think the main
line that it tries to open up the
queenside and trying to learn to get rid
of this somewhat annoying c5 form i
guess ii five is unplayable hair design
I'm not sure what if there is I mean I'm
also not sure d takes me 5 94 yeah yeah
yeah let's no I don't think I'm a direct
technical refutation come really big
nord coming with bishop maybe you can
Bishop e2 yeah it can be but if white
wood ignored it this I think like would
play this this line its own it's sort of
like French where neck has lost a couple
of 10pm but still one it's it's
certainly an okay structure but what
could could go and so there's any way f3
to come breaking up the center oh yes
every yes what reverse French Oh as
possible but yeah I think I'm we should
continue but yeah I think be sixes I'm i
think we she also played this quickly
yeah it's um it's it's very much much
fits into the position and i wad cannot
go reform achieve what you would like to
do and because before a five so destroys
widescreen side oh I heard that there
was a funny expression on girlfriend's
face off the basics I helps ensure it to
my in line to play basics I'm not really
sure the territory first I basics looks
logical but the night looks a bit
strange on b6 but I suppose there's be
foul
and on stuff um yeah I'm not sure he
often makes funny expressions when
there's nothing much going on okay
alright so so white was happy to play C
takes b6 yeah right and then Knight b6
yeah Queen B 6 doesn't make much sense
as you would allow an idea for the
temple so you take the online you know
that would get good grip on that and
then any chance especially to ya wants
to go there anyway not sure if he plays
this immediately on way to move but 96
also allows this night on a for that
should appear them to be exchanged
directly mmm I think it pretty much
everything was okay with Flex position
up to a point so now we should choose
this also can quickly see five of course
black wants to get rid of this pawn and
now look see one this has been played
very quickly and now I'm invested some
time to to figure out how he should set
up his pieces and Jung yeah yeah i think
i'm natali pogany go on chest gamescom
was saying the two main moves would be
CD or c4 maybe but see for the pawn
structure might be fragile of the c-4
hair there's biting opportunities later
with be free or e for this this is
fragile but i just wondered myself if
later it could be justified if black
could use this B file you know later
with some sort of but know that white I
don't know that's a bit ambitious c4
isn't it what do you think you're doing
is terrible it took a little yeah I
thought of this move on so but i think
that white is pretty quick in opening up
the position either would be three loi
form yeah you're bit underdeveloped yes
like so what I'm not sure maybe you form
that could be an idea or be three and
it's how to maybe maybe be three easy
and it's hard to see you but blackwood
yeah we'll keep the pawn there so you
may need to take even
I know this is such a fabled position
it's it's very symmetrical maybe even
with the pawn I'm not sure the porn on
b3 also controls the nice e4 square but
in this position is pretty symmetrical
but black has got yes some slight
development problems white could maybe
try for something here also on the a6
porn is the potential problem yeah and
you always need to take care about this
point it's it's a bit difficult you
don't want to play five as it gives away
b5 some yeah this is a bit bit
problematic I think you're taking on
your form should be should be fine
really yeah what he what he played it
it's certainly um still has got this
weakness on a six blacks position but if
you look at this I think he got a pretty
decent position so it takes to the pawn
to cement controller v5 to keep a lock
on the dark squares and it's this
strategy on the dark squares which is
echoed throughout this game in
particular c5 and e5 advisors White's
keep lock and gone over so that's even
though the pool might be a bit more
vulnerable there there's no chain around
it uh it wasn't that exploitable was it
there's no pressure on d4 hair from
black yeah exact and you need to free up
the bishop the d2 bishop so this what
it's pretty much the instant reply it
takes you for you know this should be
six makes also sense to prevent the ship
to their form you know anyway the bishop
girl so it's useful Bishop g5 yeah right
and now now this is a very interesting
point from the commentary point of view
people commenting in real time around
the world here are being a big you know
crossroads here off the consoles as Oh
Bishop takes f6 was a viable option but
personally I thought well surely black
gets a dynamic game you know he plays
like this maybe you can play like this
and done it game so later sorry pardon
me later when white castles it became an
option for Bishop f6 but at the moment
um sorry when the Queen left we'll see
black hair okay in this position after
Bishop g5 black car sold yeah so I do
want to say if you met Bishop g5 here
Abby should be fibers are just normal
but I think it's pretty much a very good
idea to capture on f6 this looks
completely anti positioner to me oh yes
sir at the man when the Queen's there
you know you don't want to give up the
dark square Bishop no I mean later so I
was jumping it head there yep winder
more 15 years he know off the castles
okay now Bishop d3 and there is a threat
of actually technically winning a porn
isn't there yeah let must play h6 not
much else so now we see Bishop h4 yeah
the sound planning in the long run to
play Bishop g3 get rid of the bishops
you know want to help them increase some
yeah the grip on ya on the dark squares
it looks like a typical French defense
strategy you get in the tower ash
variation we are often play this
maneuver to just get rid of the dark
squared bishop loosen the dark squares
yeah it's pretty similar actually an OB
should be seven of course this Bishop
it's not really great yeah I've lost the
least four games this year so far with
such a bishop on b7 in French defense
type positions sometimes it can be just
totally useless and if white clamps down
on dark squares is also imprisoning this
Bishop strategically if it's never given
you know liberation on diagonal it's
just lock down by its own structure um
so white castles and now to the very
interesting move here now which was
inviting so it was this point I was
jumping ahead earlier Queen B 8 so it is
inviting oh sorry your darting here yet
I've got very bad audio and you should
just quickly reconnect okay okay um um
okay for you call me again ah
okay okay if I do stop we definitely got
bad connection oh yeah hello okay that
all connections restore a bit okay let's
let's just continue sorry Queen B 8 I'm
sorry I'm sorry
okay so Queen b8 was played here after
after castles queen bee 8 yeah okay so
we see this logical plan instead of
Bishop f6 this was the crossroads so
Bishop f6 might be what an unwanted he
was dreaming of Bishop f6 with an active
game is that possible that black has
enough dynamic compensation to decide
this is really complete the educational
as editor it is disappear you find
control and why do they never get
anything against the king but some
commentator thought this was good for
why I think a GM Comte apparently
thought this was an option i don't know
maybe though thinking of Queen d2 a
specific idea Queen d2 to provoke f5
nope yep just to forget to anything and
hmm read this I'm not sure baby I'd wash
with only get a complete into position
but I never tried anything I'd because
it is also process if you can get away
in behave progresses judgest another
question if I got onto the position or
maybe why do get something and here
you're actually risking something as
white as it's very unfair that you don't
get anything just a new job hold on 9h
foreign Queen h5 seem like a dangerous
idea okay what would you play for
example as black here in this position
after Queenie to well if you want to go
knowledge for your new you need to
consider that I can take on h2 awesome
yeah i'm just gonna sacrifice that so
yeah maybe you can it's so it's not
question um yeah one one possibility is
to just go king dru g7 okay um right
soul sacrifice you're gonna take that
maybe not engage aid all right rock a
chainsaw and suggestion comes wine yeah
if you will give a shaky on g4 I can do
Chevy yeah okay so the promise of the G
file is real here I'm just just want to
make sure that there's white hasn't you
know maybe f4 and it starts to get a bit
creaky for black I guess I think
somewhat some GM commentate was
convinced that Bishop f6 was actually a
good move my first reaction or maybe a
little bit wash hmm well it's just a be
relatable move I think I saw the
dockworkers Lucia had a political
commentator that should take the city
horrible so horrible for who for white
or for black eye for white ok oh I make
me do I got the wrong in and sit okay
maybe that's okay maybe that's nothing
yeah everything cept the vessel this is
a bit here that how you would try to get
something going yeah in fact sister game
in club games getting rid of the dance
crab bishops and playing on dark squares
has been a major source of wins actually
from the white side this season is it is
an easy way to win sometimes just just
as a sort of you know color square
campaign just get rid of the opponent's
defensive bishop and then just
infiltrate and that's basically what
happened isn't it well sorry I don't
wanna spoil its full game there but okay
so what does black play here he
plays rook c8 yeah um he's not keen to
double white spawns it's just falling in
with white strategy to double these
pawns immediately well Ashley though
after this next poof he does actually
double white spawns he does take on g3
let's move out of awesome I took me to
ER maybe white also threatens a new way
night 25 this could be a tissue 954 yeah
it looks like a pillsbury bind attack
position with the bishop outside of the
pawn Shane no pressure on d4 for blacks
counter-attack on but yeah I mean this
looks like to be honest I don't like
blacks position and the way he's played
this so for it looks like a bad French
defense without any can't play doesn't
that position bacon Winnie hey mom not
so terribly head didn't like me would
certainly say no yeah really accurate
defense atty matically he plated
accurate defense for for quite some time
sleep but we will see the critical
corner you let it we prevent again so
they're just so Queen what the Queen d6
has some points that um maybe later
Queen before it's helping protect some
key squares in case maybe there's a
sacrifice or something it's useful
useful on d6 as a defensive and
potential attacking thing is protecting
e6 later so this is
tell me sensible look-see to yep Mahmud
II 37 um okay hanging fire friends also
protecting a six from the side yeah it's
also my wife widescreen to lacrosse to
the tech yeah he's a second I came up
never clarified really yeah it's kind of
position where it also has should be
fine yeah that'd be horrible so after
someone which is pathological yeah get
on and all 88 and our ocean I think the
critical phase yeah yeah I'll stunned
here I tried to get an answer from from
WM you know Natalia polka Nina on chess
games calm and she was convinced as well
I felt a free was the way to go just to
securely you know God c-54 night a 42 c
5 i'm surprised by night a fog as I
thought night a4 doesn't really secure
c5 and black might have my tea for which
turns out soon to be a liability nightie
for so white is playing without any porn
moves which for me as a memorable moment
of this match because Paul moves might
imply some sort of weakness and
liability to construct a free and be
four to mark out see 50 ready for motor
because the man before he wouldn't be an
equal you can also pay a 38 signs later
stage one in 94 is the awesome all right
I thought it was simply to parry the c5
square mighty foe because it is pouncing
that is kind of weakness in the last
movie that's not yeah well nitey for you
just want to defend see if I thought
that was the main points of mighty fall
and which is also just shown in the game
actually um the game shows are 90 force
a bad move and notch one should like you
let's take the speculate 94 well my
cookie ever this is not right at all
easy on the suit XE to where I should
take and then I think um the main point
is we txt to root X it who is not not
really dangerous and now i think the
cone here was in the calculation books
eh which was planned marge is my guess
um what will my dear this year a 95 and
it was fun this looks quite terrible for
Mac when you can play a five year I 595
and now what what what should watch you
he's been on the sea fowl and Mike if
you white makes a nothing with let's say
some DD nothing let's say work will play
something like a three here yeah you
cannot do anything with an eye because
is in yeah it's just be five bright
white still is better but it's not the
kind of strong here for now Oh blimey
attacking b7 yeah yeah taking you
seventh then like has the amazing move
on a mission a six Oh blimey haha didn't
see the pond yet I'm sure because it's
really cool i think i have seen
something still of back row Knight g4
actually
really should be big-screen 86 yeah I
think there's a bat kro cheapo here I
suspect yeah and legacy is winning here
if why would take so this is checkmate
oh my not even a draw it's just meat
I'll blow me I might have to that if to
you need to place first night f2 to
knock out F too fast ok I'll blimey so
King h2 rook h1 this is beautiful that's
me so hits position King h4 Oh blimey
yes oh dear oh dear that is mating isn't
it because now the king is getting mated
yes yes was my hair actually why we
should a six-game it into the computer
and that mystery isn't it does not a
sequel exactly strategically this is
good for blacks get rid of the bishops
and we can eat black doesn't have Bishop
a6 blacks in trouble here isn't it um
bishop I ate it doesn't look Pleasant
maybe something like rook I Queen a free
queen a free maybe
yeah yeah resource yeah amazing it's an
amazing use of the double porns there
the back row and the slight the rook
being unprotected bishop asics fantastic
resource so so so I you're really saying
that black this was an absolute the
first identifiable blunder in this game
was 94 yes let's look at this as a pawn
sacrifice as a is there any mileage in
it as a pawn sacrifice it so it's like
no basic okay so it's just definitely
just a pawn down there's nothing is
there queen bee for this is nothing um
just I suppose or just Queen I out here
maybe um maybe because Tommy just Quincy
to work on oh yeah Quincy to you should
be said but ok you cannot play this
really no better you get some new good
composition all of this no so Bishop
takes c8 was virtually forced then yang
to take that and then simple move from
which Gohan played for institute yes I
find this a painful reminder of some of
the games I lose in blitz wear white
simply plays very simply on the C file
which is a very obvious route into
blacks position it just seems too
obvious to win such a high level game
like this to use the C file for basic
infiltration on c7 but it's a problem
with the position isn't it with blacks
position CSUN this lady for was really a
really bad what can not in the same yes
it's a double attack basically on e4 and
c7
cuz neck sure and although neck this
next move offers efore as a pawn
sacrifice I get welcome black do here if
he doesn't he plays a very
strange-looking move now okay but what
if it you know he plays g5 bit of a
shocker but before looking at g5 audit
what can black do then here yeah this is
a problem why should you do Bishop e7
should be seven hmm yeah this wood beads
that have abnormal looking but I think
then just 95 and 95 not Queen c7.r know
Quincy 7s rooks eh ah yeah this is rob
the enteric so I think 90 no no oh yeah
cuz take sorry just let's just
demonstrate it to youtubers because
taking yeah you take the queen with the
night here okay sorry yeah okay so um so
basically this this position after
Bishop d7 you're saying for that reason
night a c5 here it's really difficult to
see what they should do he doesn't want
to give what a huge passed pawn it will
their c6 coming which is very
destructive I assume yeah it's
immediately coming to assist six also
what physics or evil even though
brooksie 888 this maybe you can take on
that table yet maybe you can just take
on dissembler could be possible there's
a Bigfoot rook c8 now um yeah looks the
ages sort of semi checkmate yeah the
night the bishop on you free so it moves
right let's say Queen anywhere yeah this
movie and then I can play with CNN v8
Queen and I've got through pieces yeah
or even stronger maybe not a five um
first right I think this should be
winning some way it's a very very very
destructive here because you don't even
have to lose the porn do you win this
we're just winning another piece maybe
green sauce it a lot I will have a three
piece of honor the piece is little hope
so hmm nice if I got something right so
that really is destructive then night a
c5 I thought this is a destructive move
it's not just highlighting a dance crew
is getting a very dangerous pass porn
here what does black play here though
sorry in this position um he can't play
Knight f6 because Knight takes b7 is
crushing isn't it because then you're
winning the rook with check yeah yeah I
did so this is really really destructive
yet ok so that's what Anand was he done
doesn't want to inhale 95 um he plays so
he plays g5 um yeah it's an outrageous
looking move creating you know another
you know more liabilities in the
position for black and also at the same
time offering this kind of dodgy porn
sacrifice which isn't accepted it's just
bypassed quite cleverly so if he had
just accepted this pawn sacrifice one
would assume black has a tiny bit of
counter play here with Bishop be seven
maybe doesn't want to say because the
main hall of the positional estate which
never have anything to do in this game
and yeah may takes him we can see for
someone's yeah but this is a nice bishop
there maybe you know we wanted on the
dagger
so it's it's just it's just not enough I
think from this position just just a
bonus not enough so mmm actually there's
a neat tactic here Bishop f3 and if it
takes there's Knight e5 here and then
you got queen before I just saw that
just saw it now without an engine so I'm
not checking with engine though but it's
there it's dangerous you don't want
bishop in the game it just shows
provides resources so queasy 7 is just
just move to keep it off just get rid of
the Queen and you're just interest rate
on seven yeah that's like simple chess I
sometimes say about simple chess if
you've got a logical advantage there's
no need to gamble your position by
entering complications and that really
just keeps all of whites advantages
intact but notably this Bishop on CA
still a prisoner so now the it's black
forced to exchange off Queens he can't
play Queen say b4 yeah good maybe just
greedy 8m c8 ouch check and I'm rook
takes eh oh dear yeah because actually I
think these seven is lost after this if
you take here there's be free isn't
there yeah actually Queen a to theirs
but maybe you take on e4 first no i
don't i don't know it's all getting a
bit hairy sorry no okay let's let's just
go back um in this position queen
beautiful Thank You sexual things oh
yeah so check you gave a check yeah but
but maybe just did let's just look
quickly at this position maybe we got
something I'll see you King g7
well f sevens loose you know so we can
keep this I'd low plank be free as an
office hmm direct testimony here you can
always play melodies early and legacy
pistols you cannot move anything what
was your going to play after minutes mp3
just because we're effectively strong
enough to find it yeah but let's say
black siphons is king a bit for away
from the check I guess 95 is looking
very powerful that's undermining and now
if the night moves there's Queen takes
have seven and the night doesn't well
that looks absolutely crushing actually
because if Queen takes d4 you taken then
you take on v8 it does look crushing 95
I'm not know F to though is a bit
vulnerable again you can just check
saying night then an ad because yeah so
you know you can just try to UM saying
the position here but what you want what
one on 28 now if I just detected B&C aid
yeah Oh even what about just Bishop
takes e4 first and then 95 isn't this
posing big questions for blank
interesting direct rice but you can
simply Inquisitor side in the position
and people have thought of art yeah okay
so i think we've given some evidence why
the queens were taken here off so okay
so rook takes e7 it's a fairly miserable
position for black with this
infiltration this horrible night on 84
is usefully protecting be too so black
stroke is less meaningful and the
bishops are total prisoner in this
structure yeah begging our pain f65 and
it's not not much to suggest yes this
this I think is the final losing well a
lot of people were now saying ball just
takes and then this night maneuver is
absolutely positionally crushing so as
f6 but there's nothing else apart from
f6 then there's no keeps it together but
it's really miserable and also I think
something like five minutes here or less
even so if if he did allow 95 it will be
very very unpleasant one assumes let's
say King you know g7 fruit for instance
um do we just I suppose we just play
Knight e5 then here anyway well I'm just
thinking to keep the bishop a prisoner
would you play 95 here or is no need for
that I mean I won't write anything on a
look if you wanted to do said like
chocolate by another woman really right
just be free then something like be free
today direct today call or you could
calculate it is a minute a tech normal
not you and then you want to go to do it
again all right yeah yes okay that's
rendus it's funny that poor bishop not
only a prisoner but also about to be
exterminated in this position what it
what a miserable game for that c8 bishop
oh dear so the whites whites bishop goes
as a prelude to victimizing blacks
LightSquared bishop so tons of
weaknesses on dark squares now so Anand
he tries something active and an active
sacrifice was virtually forced to isn't
he um it's a lot 96 win to see a cruise
ship and the only thing what you tried
is to get a little bit of activity yeah
so but it's very very effective way of
winning what they're from flake here
some 9 s6 lads you five very nice so
making sure the bishop cannot do Bishop
d7 so now night d 6 is a massive threat
just to win bishop um okay and then tack
attacks the rook the rook can just go to
a seven here and and it's not prone to
any attack at the moment of inspiration
here 95 very nice mmm I don't before men
move then you've got 96 winning
everything yeah it's torturous nightmare
it's and
right there on dark squares oh dear I've
had some losses like this and I know
what it's like on the black side this is
why I think I'm not going to play the
French next season because you end up
with pawns on light squares and
sometimes a terrible c8 bishop it's 11
reason not to play the French if you get
too much of that you don't want to see
that that scenery yeah again but ya know
some desperation moves here like
sacrifices you are our nest eight years
after this bishops 1c8 because he cannot
protect it anyway yep Oh interestingly
so he doesn't use the check no need to
use the check to take the bishop all
right yeah so he's keeping his knights
kind of in contact with central squares
here yeah of course that's very very
instructive in a way you know even you
know even the material of Greg gaining
operations that are very very nice so I
Brooksie seven but now it initially for
a second or two I thought well isn't
there a little bit can't play with these
checks and these pawns and this night
and but it's sort of proven its
illusionary so King h2 and it seemed to
be initially I thought a dangerous try
now this III yes with forcing moves
check check and now the nights and the
rook coordinate 95 he doesn't mind is
taking too long to get this Queen even
if we even if its accelerated with a
rucksack it doesn't help doesn't this
this porn
yeah white doesn't meet for Apple to
have to I said we're attacking the key
know anything can you be able get want
to get in your green doesn't help yeah
let's let's just show that so check
check this wouldn't help having the
Queen here because there's an imminent
threat of night g6 check and then rook
g7 mates and the Queen and night
helpless hair anything to protect those
we're asking let's just show that how
let's just show that that that meeting
sorry that mating pattern with the two
nights sorry my check yep
try to meet Paula me and rook g7 it
shows shows the coordination of nights
let me just undo that variation um so so
in the game so I've put in some some
false variations for the game now let's
just go back to get the game score so in
in the game okay so after e 2 nite takes
c6 was actually the final move of the
game yeah I felt actually quite bad for
an answer be honest that he kind of lost
the game more than maybe it was one but
maybe you know now I'm looking at it
objectively white did place supremely
well to avoid any complications didn't
he it didn't take any risk yeah you
control this very nicely hmm always had
a little bit of something and it it
looks like at least from this pretty
yeah it's only didn't do a deep analysis
but it looks like black maybe could keep
the position in in a sort of only a
slight advantage kind of way but you
needed to play very accurately which she
didn't do hmm so um yeah I think okay
this doesn't look like a great game Ian
especially yeah from next point of view
let's do a quick a quick overview sorry
quit over here in summary should we just
quickly go fly through it just quit
overview in summary yeah I'm so um a six
so we saw c5 the novelty here marking
out the dark squares and Sobeys b6
didn't work out particularly well in
terms of dark square controlling this
bishop on CA um so
so sorry what it's difficult so what
were you going to say so I had
interrupted you there sorry you were
going to say something else I had all
the correct yeah you've had some
resources down and yeah it's just
quicker on replay again and then say
something about the father crossover the
mesh of course a bit of speculation hmm
it's it's it looks as though many games
on many game statistically lost because
of this c8 bishop it is one of more
difficult pieces to develop all those of
Y squared may also be 65 this is Bishop
this you know you're a major concern
yeah come watch the vid Constitution
alright attended correctly it's also
possible to edit we needed a regulated a
yeah this bishops resourcefully use the
a6 square in that key variation we saw
for instance maybe this kind of
miscalculation oh you don't know you've
got those off days and maybe it's also a
case of from this kind of match which
has not six drawers and maybe sometimes
it's even maybe good good fair player to
loose again to really wake up and start
start to play more aggressively yes to
be actually more emotionally engaged in
the match if he was kind of yeah he's
going to be more emotionally engaged
hopefully he you know he'll try and you
know play aggressively um tomorrow we'll
have the white pieces tomorrow
money so um this was actually a very
interesting parallel to the 1995 match
which I'm played against Kasparov where
the aid first eight games were drawn and
then we she won Game nine and actually
took the lead in the match and after
this Kasparov struck back immediately
with his knights rook sacrifice i'm not
quite sure wait sacrificed half of his
pieces and one game 10 and after this
completely crumbled away from the she
write this really woke up his farm up in
this match though he needs something
simulator yeah because objectively it
gets very difficult miles only five
games left and gear for the stuff to
beat so i'm i think this was one of the
best i just couldn't understand the
difference or wild better than a friend
I think apparently Karpov was a guest
commentator and was mentioning a free
apparently I think a few people have
mentioned a free hair so for me this was
an amazing moment where even if you know
in practice you don't see a variation
difference from a theoretical point of
view why it's not committing porns which
are potential targets so it's better to
play theoretically even if you can't
calculate it without any weaknesses and
let not commit any porn weaknesses so no
a for really is a very non-committal but
seemingly you know gets advantage anyway
yeah I think it was very nicely played
by wide to the skin yeah but you would
be very hard-pressed to to find some
some mistake or something and he's from
if you look at it superficially it looks
a very nice very nice done um now this
may be one of the most beautiful or
maybe the critical um I am yeah naive or
so allows a forcing continuation rook
takes eh I know the artist if you
compare this to the game yes
och rotate where he was the score now
move on hmm because maybe you should go
for the tree keep being upon down and
he's having a bishop maybe this would
have been better hmm i suppose g5 I mean
a lot of people were were shocked I
think a lot of GM's would be shocked
just visually by g5 it's anyway yeah it
sort of weakens the second rank as well
I mean it wakens all sorts of things but
it does it did have some tactical
implications later for you know
potential counterplay chances to
undermine everybody net it never worked
out like that because of another of
another forcing move operation initiated
yeah it's any any ideas of of weakening
yeah and M rupee for zar just just just
dreamland now are they after this
forcing sequence with Bishop takes e4
its yeah once you see Bishop efore in
this night maneuver to c4 it's a
terrible dark square infiltration I mean
yes to say the least the rooks
continually double attacking both of
those the Knights have their rampant
dark squares very soon after f5 it's
it's sort of unfortunate in many many
ways of the 94 oh dear oh dear just
terrible to look at you yeah army and
don't need to look at it from next point
of injuring a war game so yeah it's okay
but the interesting try at the end to
sacrifice well was basically forced and
then ok another forcing sequence to get
a mating net by force which was
well calculated so 95 so these 27
hundreds are really worth it you know
when it when there is a force my hittas
lot just computers will find it it was a
force mate with two nights in the rook
not minding like the porn getting too
dangerous proportions so it is placed
night takes a six yeah actually special
I think now I'm not easily selenium
before that anyway always say okay
withdrawal so bad I can always win again
later or it doesn't have an image to
draw people want you to throw but I
wouldn't the rapid or whatever yeah yeah
things much more exciting now yeah
you're right it's been it's that
everything's I think everyone's woken up
now it's this match cooking the players
there's a non-symmetrical Paul structure
which produced the decisive result which
does show that the pawns of the soul of
chess something okay thanks Chris I hope
everyone on YouTube enjoyed that will be
uploading this to both of our channels
kingscrusher and chess explain channels
make an excellent really love this
weather okay okay all right okay okay
Flynn so much so and see on the next
game hopefully Chris and and see I hope
everyone enjoyed the country okay thanks
very much yes yes